thank you
guys
wait you're making you're making me
shake
seven
thank you you're gonna be here hold
somebody are you throwing Josie and
stuff
going straight line scene when you're
rolling and make you a little laugh
again uh first of all it's Off Script
but thank you so much for being here and
I love you and we did some damage
we need some damage in the 80s
I heard an expression the other day I
never heard before someone said oh they
were 80s famous
yeah it's not a [ __ ] that was a
different deal
anyway
and it had a serious business
thank you Academy for honoring me with
the gene Hershel humanitarian award it
is a wholly unexpected honor and I'm
truly grateful
special thanks to Bonnie Arnold Davis
Guggenheim
Bob zimekus
Bob Gale
the two Bobs Steven Spielberg and Laura
Dern
[Applause]
I actually know those people
this is so cool
also thanks to Bruce Springsteen for
that song you heard at the end of
David's piece it was his piece
they sort of a personal anthem
no repeat baby no retreat baby no repeat
I never repeat no retreat baby no
surrender
and uh Hey reminders of this line that
the person had a class how to get away
from those fools you'll learn more from
a three-minute record baby they never
learned in school I don't know that was
completely true
but I did leave High School in the 11th
grade
sold my guitar
and moved to LA like right over there in
the corner of the fox line and an alley
behind Shirley way and moved in star for
a while
I'm not bragging God forbid anybody who
tries to do the same thing
I told the history teacher reminded to
stop it
no no not yet
you you wonder what Parkinson's doing
I told the history teacher of my plan
and he said Fox you're never going to be
cute forever
I had no idea how to respond to that
so I said maybe just long enough sir
maybe just long enough
turns out we were both right
years later my son Sam insisted that the
30-something me or my JD
and so I did I got that covered
my career as a risk taker and
opportunist started to hit full stride
during my first days
then months and years in the American
film and television industry I booked
some jobs dug some landlords
delve in a few dumpsters
and eventually I found myself
unbelievably on a TV series called
Family Ties
my boss on family times was a larger
than life enormously gifted bearer of a
man and when I say bear I don't just
mean Teddy I mean full and grizzly
Gary David Goldberg was my friend
I don't get restarted
was my friend and my mentor
and I still miss him every day
he taught me how to be a dedicated
professional actor and a responsible
human being
introduced me to the concept of to whom
much is given much is required
I think that's John F Kennedy's wording
but I also recognize the concept is
taught to me by my parents Phil and Bill
Fox
who by the way would love this
foreign
Irish people Covell too
my mom and dad were kind and generous
people and the Very values were very
clear and visible to their core
I didn't think they've been given so
much so I didn't think I fully
understood the lesson they worked their
asses off putting on an open energy and
raising me and my four siblings Karen
Steve Jackie and Kelly but of course
they wouldn't see it as any hardship at
all
when I left school in my home in my
country
I wasn't leaving my mom and dad I was
just doing what felt right for me
he believed in my passion
my optimism not so much
they were risk averse
and now a few short years later I was on
top of the world I had a hit television
show two movies in the can and it was
all good in the neighborhood
this is when Gary started to talk to me
about a bigger neighborhood about the
obligation I had to help out where I
could
Gary introduced me to other
philanthropic mentors all stunning
examples of doing good as a major part
of doing right you're doing well Bob's
Mecca it's Bob Gale Steven Spielberg
Jeffrey cashenberg Brandon tartikoff
Peter Van attack
and Bob philpine
these were strong men and also strong
women helped me along the way like Nancy
Ryder
Leslie Sloan
and Nancy Byron kind of miss her
Judas weiner Nancy Gates and Dr Susan
bressman and just when you think things
wouldn't get any better they got better
just before they got worse
I met Tracy better
Sam was born better eventually we had
three fantastic daughters the Queen of
Scotland and Esme better better
thank you
somewhere in there around 29 I was
diagnosed with Parkinson's I told I was
told I only had 10 years left to work
that was shitty
that's what happened
the hardest part of my diagnosis was
grappling with the answer with the
certainty of this of the diagnosis and
the uncertainty of the situation I mean
it would get worse the diagnosis was
definite the progress was indefinite and
uncertain
it's crazy
Tracy made it clear that she was with me
for the duration
I just gotten so much [ __ ]
but uh
uh my young son Sam didn't didn't know
he didn't have a choice
I entered into this then I entered into
seven years of denial trying to make
sense of it all the kid who left Canada
convinced that he would make anything
happen it's by working hard and by
believing now I had to talk later in
front of him I told very few people and
they kept my secret stop it
then there were all kinds of doctors who
helped me understand physical processes
that were at work or not at work in my
brain in this case may be
finally I felt like I needed to tell
everybody
I understood it would have a huge impact
on my career but just by this time I was
doing Spin City and I didn't know if an
audience could laugh if they knew I was
struggling I had to figure out how best
delivered the news so I told Barbara
Walters and People magazine
remember this was at the dawn of the
internet and in those days if you want
to get news that you saw People magazine
Barbara Walters
well for simpler times
what happened next was remarkable the
outpouring of support from the public at
large and the Beautiful reaction from
all of my peers in the entertainment
business all of you
thank you and the people that I worked
with was was transformative
then I reached out to the Parkinson's
Community itself patients families their
doctors leading scientists in the field
and I struck and instruct me that
everybody
it struck me that everything I've been
given success my life with Tracy my
family had prepared me for this profound
opportunity and responsibility it was a
gift as my friend Jordan staffordopolis
pointed out the film I referred to as
Parkinson's is the gift that keeps on
taking gifts that keeps on taking
and showing up for a handful
um but it truly has been a gift once I
became engaged in learning about the
disease every interaction every new
piece of information should I gather
every researcher or NIH official I
talked to all confirmed the science was
ahead of the money
the answers could be unlocked with the
right Investments it was also clear that
an aging underserved patient-based could
use some help in getting their message
without patients let me know that if I
could push they would push they put
their weight behind me sometimes shaky
and they'd push alongside me and we
would push together
this was the impetus for the Michael J
fox foundation for Parkinson's research
I didn't want to call it that
I wanted to call it PDQ and I told Tracy
and she said pedicure
now I'm really in trouble
now I'm not in trouble
uh that's what I'm gonna say well yeah
there was nothing heroic beyond what I
did it was the gathered forces of many
people as I consider downsizing my
professional career to shift my energies
towards finding better treatments and
resources for the Parkinson's Community
I sought help from many smart people
close to home like Tracy and special
friends at Curtis and Carolyn Shanker
who I want to get this thank you guys
I'm going to stop
curious and Carolyn Shanker who
surrendered their role at exes to me
remember rolodexes
they were 80s famous
to help raise money for our initial
Grant my producer
a partner my producing partner Nell Fort
Mary one of our first board members
jumped in and on a meticulous organizer
of the battle plan jumped in and created
one most notably Debbie Brooks my
co-founder at the fox Foundation took my
motto purity of motive and and became
the Catalyst in the engine that has
driven us to our success
we it's going to fall down is it
oh
I don't know what I feel worse about
wait
drop it
okay
uh we assemble the board of achievers
from around the world and over the next
20 years outline the path to a cure that
we're working hard to realize even as we
sit here today with 1.5 billion dollars
in research so far
foreign
I am so grateful to all these people and
thousands more who will make a world
without Parkinson's a reality
I'm not sure I I communicated all that
well
but it's humbling in the deepest way to
stand here and accept your kindness and
your approbation when truly every effort
is being driven by others so deserving
this attention
I'm grateful to them and to you because
my optimism is fueled by my gratitude
and with gratitude optimism is
sustainable
I can't believe I've been standing here
for this long
it's a miracle
now I definitely can't walk and carry
this thing so I asked that Tracy to once
again to carry the weight
[Applause]
[Music]